i'm joined by forms mc forbes mackenzie
chief executive of mckenzie intelligence
uh
very good to see you forbes thanks so
much for for joining us so let's start
on
uh mario paul and particularly the
steelworks of course very very hard for
for western journalists to get close to
it to really know exactly what's going
on but but what are the the gathering of
intelligence that you've been able to do
tell us about the latest including some
of the the satellite images that we have
thank you for having me on the satellite
data there's been cloud cover since the
29th of april and i believe yesterday
and we're going to see that in a second
was the first satellite data that's um
come in
some drone footage as well as purported
to be of a recent source and as
intelligencer we always ask the question
how good is the data we're getting
where's it coming from and kind of what
does it mean
um but we're about to see some detailed
pictures
of this the steelworks here this is a
planet labs picture it's three meter
resolution what does that mean it means
it's not the kind of stuff you see in
google earth but from an analyst
perspective it gives a lot of insight
and where we've had not a lot of data
since the 29th of april it's the first
time we've started to to see now if bomb
damage assessment
there is a lot of bomb damage assessment
to be done that's to say a lot of
munitions have been dropped by the
russians which ties in with some of the
data that we're seeing from drones which
have come from a russian source uh we've
also seen some video released from the
donetsk people's uh republic fighters uh
what can we learn about that the
bombardment that's been going on uh in
mario paul from from these these images
this image that we see here comes from a
sequence and it's been suggested that
thermo thermobaric weapons a really
nasty band weapon system have been used
it's an area weapon which we would
expect to be used but this particular
sequence we see here is air dropped
munitions and we suspect is to target
what's going on underneath the ground
there's a real complex uh system of
tunnels where the defenders are um let's
zoom out a little bit and uh discuss
what's going on broadly in these of
course many that have escaped from mario
paul have made it to zafaria relative
safe haven or all relative of course uh
what are the latest points of action
here in the east
well the main effort hasn't really
changed it's still the donbass
we see the kind of the yellow and red
hatched areas where russian advances
have been made um i've been talking
about advances of two to three
kilometers per day which for a
maneuverous capability which the
russians would aspire to be is not quick
enough
that's really because they're only
moving with the safety of their own
artillery fire and so some advances
there on the use of combined arms
and but certainly you can see the arrows
coming from the north to the south and
then the south to the north we can see
that the attempt to fill in the donbass
region to the black to the black line
which is uh northeast to in into them
south
that is the special
operation mission to fill in that air
that area and this focus to try and
connect this area you're suggesting that
their progress there has been slow over
the last week relative to what they
would have liked to have seen the
russians it has been slow two three
kilometers a day from a modern military
is very slow let's touch uh as well on
on the sort of further reports of
ongoing missile attacks long-range
missile attacks uh i guess not just in
the east and all areas of ukraine yeah
so what we have here um we we call that
the deep
the deep battle so the ukrainians are
being reinforced
and they've been reinforced with kitten
equipment from the west that must go
through transportation nodes and it will
be held at certain locations and the
russians are currently
targeting those locations ukraine's are
also being very clever in maneuvering
their own forces so if we have an
overwhelming russian majority that can
be matched by ukrainians moving their
own troops to getting
an equalization of troops on the grounds
and inhibiting bridges trains that stops
the ukrainians moving their kitten
equipment and people okay forbes great
stuff thanks so much for joining us to
discuss the latest on the ground